listening to a film courage women
and Kerry Wood
we talk with you
it's uh it's hard to know because I I
didn't go to film school and you know I
when you run into people who did go to
film school I think they they have the
technical knowledge that I definitely
don't have um when I'm you know talking
to my DP or the gaffer or anyone in
there talking about cameras and lenses
and everything my eyes just kind of
glaze over and it's just like just make
it pretty I don't know what that means
so I know that you know from the people
who did that they have that knowledge
and so they can say this is the camera
we need this to the lens as the lighting
all that stuff you know I still feel
like you know I didn't go to film school
why does anyone care about what I have
to say about making movies and then I
have to stop and think oh wait i
actually had made movies and i just had
them distributed and we won awards so
maybe I do have something to say but
every now and then it's sort of like
really